fresh off of sitting there right at
courtside with the wit grew spec the
owner of the Celtics Drew Bledsoe how
are you drew I'm doing great rich man I
was fired up last time and I was so fun
maybe not your faucet you know this this
this Celtics team it's cool man they got
their two biggest stars on the sideline
they've got a bunch of young kids with
Al Horford leading them and they're
playing great basketball it's fun to
watch and then you've got I mean just
seeing you and your in your Rozier the
third jersey and he signed it right you
put an autographed jersey hot the [ __ ]
the crowd last night it was great man
it's this uh this whole thing man it's
it's one of those kills I think just
couldn't have happened 15 years ago but
in this social media world we live and
it just became this thing and it's been
it's been a lot of fun another you know
she's got to meet Terry yesterday for
the first time and I really like the kid
love his game I love his energy man
school kid so do you know who Eric
Bledsoe is Drew
absolutely like my my more athletic
cousin cousin Eric I I actually reached
out to Eric I filmed the deal for Game
seven when the Celtics were playing the
Fox I reached out it was a man purse
once you know really respect your game
and just havin some fun and then I sent
him supply so you know hopefully there's
no hard feelings that's correct
so when you say this wouldn't have
happened 15 years ago you're just
talking about social media in general
what you're saying
well I mean I mean this you know the
must do you know Terry's a terrorist
mistake you know you know Colin Eric
through a pursed of also it's sort of a
funny mistake man Terry's so young I'm
not sure you but I do who the heck I was
but it was an honest mistake but then
for that thing to just catch fire and
turn into this whole thing I just don't
think that happened 15 years ago so who
reached out to you how did you first
hear about it because when you're you
know my son my phone kind of blew up
when when when Terry uh you know made
the mistake it's honest mistake you know
and called called Eric by my name
instead my phone blew up I got all these
text messages people back here thought
it was pretty funny and then and then
you know Eric kind of threw some
gasoline on fire when he said he didn't
even know who carries Rozier was so
it was funny and it's fun but it's just
really fun for me to come back and
reconnect with the fans of Boston and be
around this Celtics team has been just
cool yeah you know what Bru I'd love to
dive into that a little bit Drew Bledsoe
here on the Rich Eisen show and and when
you say it's cool to reconnect with the
Boston sports fan let's dive in and out
a little bit more what do you mean by
that
true well do you know when I got I got
to the Patriots in 1993 a team again
team has been pretty it pretty awful and
that the the themes of I was you know
privileged to be a part of it we sort of
set the stage for what the Patriots have
become you know there's not there's a
there's a young fan base out here that
doesn't even know the Patriots football
existed before 2001 but some of the
older fans remember the hard times that
really remember those teams but I was
blessed to be a part I've really
qualified and then for you to just let
everybody know who Drew Bledsoe is in
the same way that Terry Rozier wants
everyone to know his name is that is
that simple is that is that a simple on
a national level you know a lot of
people think that that I'm just a guy to
lost uh you know lost his job when I got
hurt you siffredi but you know fans out
here they have a little more sense of
history and they know that there's a
little bigger than that
and I'd be remiss if I didn't point out
the numerology in all this drew okay
yeah how funny is that right you know
Tyrese number 11 it goes down and and
number 12 comes in and you know sort of
an unknown guy and and starts lighting
it up so yeah there is there are some
parallels there although I I do think
it's a little different I think I think
there's going to be a spot for for Kyrie
when he comes back he's one of the one
of the great one of the great basketball
players that uh you know in the world
today and I don't think his jobs gonna
be gone when he comes back to this
injury well interesting drew we were
talking about this at the top of the
show here is that 25 times Boston sports
fans have seen their teams wind up in
the Final Four since 2002 calendar year
2002
and the quarterback who won the that
first appearance in the final four in
that AFC champion what would that would
that quarterbacks name be in that to toe
oh that's Eric Bledsoe his long-lost
cousin came in him on that game you know
Matt it was it was fun I will tell you
Amanda the Boston sports fan since uh
since you know really since 2001 they
have been awfully spoiled you know it's
like talking to out the dad of one of
these these kids it's a you know
probably late teens now and you know
every year just you know as they hate
that which one of our teams thinks gonna
win a championship this year hmm so they
listen in a little bit of a bubble that
don't realize how hard it is for most
teams with a world championship you know
interesting also drew here I noticed in
these but in the social media world that
you're discussing that you've been
having your fun
you're also branding I noticed when you
put your scary Terry t-shirt on you were
holding up a bottle of wine which I
thought was very savvy of you let's
let's let's give some pop let's give
some run yeah double back Cabernet one
of the great wines in the entire world
and it's uh it's been a super fun
project we go we went back to my little
hometown and Walla Walla Washington it's
part of the winery a little over a
decade ago now and it's been it's been a
lot of fun man wine sells fast and we
get to have fun you know traveling and
quote-unquote marketing wine by going to
cool spots next one and and you you know
the old log I'm glad it's working out it
appears to be working out drew because
you heard that old joke about you know
how you make a small fortune in the wine
business
exactly you start with a large fortune
yeah it's an expensive endeavor but you
know a few things right you can you can
make it sustainable and I've got a
killer team up there that that really
makes great wine for us and so it
allowed us to uh allowed us to actually
turn it into a little bit of a business
you know what I'd love to do Drew's
maybe the Rich Eisen show should have
some sort of sports wine-tasting here
you and coz waxen Woodson is yeah you
got you got you got Rick Myers making
some great wine and Napa you got
dan Marino and Damon's year two
partnered up and they're making some
killer wine up in the in the northwest
we could have a little a little you know
NFL wine showdown Vermeil Vermeil and
Dick Vermeil yep to make it's good wine
so yeah there's a move in uh you know
it's your world you know Jim Nantz
they just wine cooling Pollock that's
right look at a lot of these a lot of
these sports guys trying to pretend like
we're sophisticated and I started making
wine let's do it let's do this drew
you're gonna hear from me very shortly
before I let you go so how many more are
you do we expect to see you at the
Eastern Conference Finals to I mean
you're you're now officially a good luck
charm true they're gonna have to bring
me out in the last five or six years I'm
undefeated going to Celtics games even
when they weren't very good a couple
years ago we showed up and they picked
up a W so yeah I think I have to make
that prospect you terrific in the next
couple weeks I don't know if you you
know what off the top of your head what
is your career record against Cleveland
maybe maybe you should go show up in
Cleveland with this number 12 Jersey you
know that's I think like most like most
players in the playoffs back in 94 but
outside of that I think it's pretty good
that's right and who is the coach of
that Cleveland team drew guy that's gone
on to moderate success Bill Belichick's
unbelievable it's amazing how things
work in this life drew it really really
is thanks for the time that was a lot of
fun watching you have fun really well
thanks right yeah I really was funny
knows I was sitting there with with Rick
respected the owner of the Celtics and I
was telling him you know they they do
the national anthem and then they do the
introductions and all of a sudden my
body just starts to react and starts to
act like it wants to go play obviously
not basketball so that would not be good
but but you know even at 46 they're
still selectman all right give me the
ball I can give you a good quarter you
guys I'll give you a good quarter I may
not be able to go beyond that but if it
gets solid for it oh man drew great
chatting with you let's let's chat again
soon okay yeah we're getting drinks mine
right tomorrow
that's drew blood so the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience